TO ORDER. TODAY WE ARE HOLDING
OUR HEARING IN ROOM 2200 OF THE
Þ STREET BUILDING. WE HAVE A
MUCH SMALLER AGENDA THAN WE HAD
LAST WEEK, BUT WE WOULD STILL
LIKE TO HAVE ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN THE HEARING WITH A QUORUM.
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE NEW
TO THIS PROCESS, THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE THAT LOOKS AT THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE BILL. IF
IT WAS TO PASS. AND SO ANYTHING
THAT COSTS MONEY, ANYTHING OVER,
$100,000 OR $150,000 OF GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS, COMES TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND GETS PLACED ON
SUSPENSE, WHICH MEANS WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT THEM ALL TOGETHER. SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS ON
SUSPENSE TODAY. IT MEANS THAT
YOUR, WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
I'M GOING TO CALL. THE BILLS
WILL MOVE FAIRLY QUICKLY, WE
HAVE 33 MEASURES ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. LAST WEEK WE HAD 350. SO
WE WERE HERE FOR MANY, MANY
HOURS. AND OUT OF THOSE 33
MEASURES, TWO OF THEM ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR A DUE PASS MOTION,
WHICH MEANS TWO OF THEM ARE
UNDER THE $150,000 THRESHOLD.
AND WILL GO STRAIGHT TO THE TO
THE FLOOR. THE REMAINING ITEMS
ARE SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. AS
I SAID, WE HAVE ONE SUSPENSE
FILE BILL THAT WILL HAVE A
PRESENTATION, BUT THE AUTHORS
FROM THE FOR THE REMAINING
SUSPENSE BILLS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IT MEANS THEY WILL
NOT BE HERE TO PRESENT THEIR
BILL, SO WE'LL BE TAKING
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC ON
EACH AND EVERY ITEM, EVEN IF THE
AUTHOR HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
AND WE HAVE ONE BILL, AB 2297 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, THAT
IS LISTED ON OUR FILE, BUT IT
WILL BE REPORTED DIRECTLY TO THE
FLOOR PURSUANT TO SENATE RULES
28.8. SO WE WILL NOT HAVE
TESTIMONY ON THAT BILL TODAY. SO
IF YOU'RE HERE FOR AB 2297, THAT
THAT FILE HAS ALREADY WILL WILL
BE MOVING TO THE FLOOR AND WILL
TAKE IT UP THERE, AS USUAL, WE
WILL EXTEND A COURTESY TO ANY OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT SHOW
UP IN PERSON AND WILL ALLOW THEM
TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS OUT OF
AGENDA ORDER AS THEY SHOW UP. SO
IF YOU SEE US JUMP TO OTHER
BILLS, THAT'S THE REASON IS
BECAUSE WE'RE HONORING THEIR
TIME AND THEY THEY'VE GOT OTHER
WORK TO DO. SO BEFORE WE BEGIN,
I WANT TO REMIND ANY WITNESSES
TO LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL. IN
OTHER WORDS, HOW HOW MUCH IT'S
GOING TO COST. PLEASE REFRAIN
FROM LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS
AND REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY IN
YOUR IN YOUR COMMENTS. AND WHEN
WE GET TO THE PUBLIC COMMENTS,
IF YOU CAN SAY YOUR NAME, IF YOU
BELONG TO AN ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE, THAT WOULD BE THAT. THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. THAT'S THE
PROCESS. WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
YET. SO WE, WE WERE HOPING WE'D
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE DON'T. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO START AS A
COMMITTEE. AND THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO GET START GOING THROUGH
THE BILLS. AND YOU DON'T YOU
WON'T HAVE TO SIT AROUND AND
WAIT. SO, WOULD APPRECIATE IF
ANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT ARE LISTENING TO THIS, IF
THEY COULD SHOW UP SO WE COULD
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, IT'LL MAKE
THE HEARING GO A LITTLE BIT
SMOOTHER. SO WE'RE READY TO
START, THE FIRST BILL UP IS AB
FOUR, WHICH IS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. WANT TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO, TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR?
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FOUR? DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE, ETHAN
MACHADO, ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE HAVE
NO FILE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WE'RE GOING TO WAIT
UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM. MOVING ON
TO AB 2240 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS ITEM. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? STRAIGHT
TO THE MIC. ONE AT A TIME. YOU
CAN HAVE A LITTLE LINE RIGHT
HERE IS THIS SUPPORT? SUPPORT
RIGHT NOW? YEAH. JOSE LUIS
CISNEROS NÓI LA PROPUESTA AB
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT WAS A
NO. MIGUEL RIVERA. DEL DEL
CENTRO MIGRANTE DE PARLIER. NO.
A LA PROPUESTA OF VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT'S A NO. AS WELL. OKAY MY
NAME IS MANUEL PEREZ DEL CENTRO,
PARLIER Y NÓ A LA PROPUESTA
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. GRACIAS
WE'VE BEEN GETTING TO KNOW
AGAPITO VILLALON. VENGO DEL
CENTRO DE PARLIER. NÓ A LA
PROPUESTA A VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
MUCHAS GRACIAS. THAT'S ALSO A NO.
MY NAME IS JOSE RAMIRO MEZA
IBARRA Y VENGO DEL CENTRO
MIGRATORIO DE PARLER Y NØ LA
PROPUESTA A 22 CUARENTA MUCHAS
GRACIAS. THANK YOU. THAT'S
ANOTHER NO. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS RODOLFO ACEVEDO. I'M
HERE TO SAY NO TO AB 2240. I'M
COMING FROM A HONEY LANE IN LODI,
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S OFF TO THE LEFT. UP FRONT
THERE. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
GUADALUPE. MINGO DEL CAMPO DE LA
Â. NØ A LA CUARENTA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANOTHER NÓ. BUENOS
DIAS, SONIA MENDEZ. FRENCH CAMP
MIGRANT CENTER. NO TO AB 2240.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU KNOW.
NO, NO. ALABADOS CUARENTA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANOTHER NÓ. I'M
JENNY SAKAKURA. I'M ADVOCATING
FOR, FARM WORKERS BY SAYING NO
TO AB 2240. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUENOS DIAS A TODOS NOMBRES
WILFRIDO ORTEZ AVALOS MINGO DE
CAMPO DE BUENA VISTA,
CALIFORNIA. MINGO ALAVEZ ÁP
CUARENTA. NO. NO. LA PROPUESTA.
MUCHAS GRACIAS, SENOR. ANOTHER.
NO BUENOS DIAS, PEDRO SALCIDO,
R-TEXAS, FRENCH CAMP. NO A LA
CUARENTA. GRACIAS. ANOTHER NO.
BUENOS DIAS, VENGO DEL CENTRO DE
PARLIER, PARA DECIR C¯ NO A LA
PROPUESTA A 22 CUARENTA MUY
BIEN. GRACIAS ANOTHER NO. BUENOS
DIAS. SOY VERONICA, MISS
HERNANDEZ. VENGO DEL CENTRO
MIGRATORIO DE PARLIER Y NÓ A LA
PROPUESTA ÁP VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS. THANK YOU. ANOTHER NO.
MUY BUENOS DIAS. HONORABLE MESA
DEL PRESIDIO PUBLICO IN GENERAL.
MY NAME IS MARTHA ZAMUDIO.
CALDERON Y VENGO DEL CENTRO
MIGRATORIO DE PARLIER A
MANIFESTAR ME PORQUE ESTAMOS EN
CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA A
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. MUCHAS GRACIAS. THANK
YOU. ANOTHER NAME IS ERMELINDA
VENGO DEL CAMPO DOS ORTEZ NÓ A
LA PROPUESTA A CUARENTA Y BIEN.
GRACIAS HI. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS GUADALUPE MODESTO. I'M A
VENGO DE LA FRENCH CAMP. CAMPO
DOS Â NÓ A LA PROPUESTA A
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS ROMAN
MODESTO. I COME FROM THE MIGRANT
CENTER, FROM FRENCH CAMP. LET ME
SAY NO TO THE AB 2240. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS LUIS
MAGDALENO. ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LA
PROPUESTA NÓ DOS CUARENTA. MUY
BIEN. GRACIAS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY NAME IS MARIA CRUZ.
VENGO DE ARTES Y DOS DE FRENCH
CAMP. NO. LA NØ AL ÁP VEINTIDOS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GRACIAS.
VENGO DEL CAMPO DOS THE FRENCH
CAMP. NO A LA VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS MARIA DE LOS ANGELES. OCHO
GARCIA Y NO VENGO DE FRENCH CAMP
DEL CAMPO. DOS Y NÓ A LA
PROPUESTA A 22 CUARENTA. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. BUEN DIA. SOY LA SENORA
MARIA OCHOA. VENGO DEL CAMPO.
DOS Y NÓ A LA PROPUESTA DE DOS
CUARENTA. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS.
ME NOMBRE ES ADRIANA TRUJILLO.
VINCO DEL CAMPO DE PARLIER Y NØ
A LA PROPUESTA ÁP 2020. GRACIAS.
MUCHAS GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. YO
VENGO DE WATSONVILLE DEL CAMPO.
BUENA VISTA Â NÓ A LA VOZ DE
LOS CUARENTA. MUCHAS GRACIAS,
SENOR. BUENOS DIAS, MY NAME IS
RUBY CORTEZ. VENGO DEL CENTRO
MIGRANT NIELSEN DE LOS NÓ A LA
CUARENTA. TENEMOS NUESTRAS
VIVIENDAS A PERDER PROGRAMA
MIGRANT APOYA NUESTROS
ESTUDIANTES, Y SABEMOS QUÉ ES EL
UNICO PROGRAMA ESPECIAL DISENADO
PARA NOSOTROS LOS TRABAJADORES
DEL CAMPO? GRACIAS POR ESCUCHAR.
GRACIAS. MUCHAS GRACIAS. YO
SANTIAGO. CALDERON DÍAS NØ LA
PROPUESTA ÁP CUARENTA CAMPO HA
NIELSEN LODI. BIEN GRACIAS.
HOLA. BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES
GUADALUPE SARA. TANGANA VENGO
DEL CAMPO DE FRENCH CAMP. ORTEZ
DOS Â. TAMBIÉN ESTOY EN CONTRA
DE LA PROPOSICION A CUARENTA.
GRACIAS, GRACIAS. HI. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
JUAREZ, AND I'M HERE TO SAY NO
TO AB 2240. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUENOS DIAS. VENGO DE LA THESIS
DOS FRENCH CAMP. MY NAME IS JOSE
GRIMALDO Y NÓ A LA 22 CUARENTA
BIEN. GRACIAS OCTAVIO SOLORIO.
I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR FARM
WORKERS, AND I SAY NO TO 2240.
THANK YOU. ALMA RODRIGUEZ NO ON
AB 2240. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR LISTENING. THANK YOU. HOLA.
BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS ADRIAN
RODRIGUEZ. VOTO NO DE LA RENTA.
MUY BIEN. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS.
MY NAME IS JUAN QUIROZ. VENGO
DEL CAMPO. MIGRATORIO DE
WATSONVILLE Y DIJO QUÊ NO A LA
2020. MUY BIEN. GRACIAS, SENORA.
BUENOS DIAS, ROGELIO VACA. ESTOY
EN CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. GRACIAS,
GRACIAS. QUÉ TAL? BUENOS DIAS.
ME NOMBRE ES VALENTIN. CALDERON.
VENGO DE WATSONVILLE DEL CAMPO.
BUENA VISTA ESTE ME RESPUESTA ES
NØ A LA 2022. CUARENTA ESTE
EXIGIMOS VIVIENDA PARA LAS
PERSONAS C¯ QUIEREN TODO EL ANO
Y TAMBIÉN NOS ESTAMOS EN CONTRA
DE ESTA PROPUESTA PORQUE NO
TENEMOS TRABAJOS DE TODO EL ANO
PARA SUSTENTAR LA RENTA PAGAR
TODO EL ANO. GRACIAS. GRACIAS.
BUENOS DIAS. SOY LA SENORA
MARAVILLA CALDERON Y VENGO EN
CONTRA DE LA VENTA. CUARENTA
PORQUE SOMOS TRABAJADORES DEL
CAMPO. ES UN SALARIO MINIMO NO
NOS ALCANZA PARA PAGAR MAS RENTA
DE LA QUÊ. TENEMOS LA RENTA. QUÉ
ESTAMOS PAGANDO ES DEMASIADO A
VECES PARA NOSOTROS PARA EL
SUELO. QUÉ ESTAMOS RECIBIENDO.
MUCHAS GRACIAS SENOR. OKAY. MUY
BIEN. HOLA. MY NAME IS YESENIA
CALDERON. VENGO DEL CENTRO DE
BUENA VISTA. DIGO NØ A LA FUENTE
DE CUARENTA, POR FAVOR. AYUDANOS
MUCHAS GRACIAS. HOLA. MY NAME IS
CONCEPCION GARCIA. VENGO DEL
CAMPO. BUENA VISTA Y DIGO NØ A
LA PROPUESTA VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS, SENORA. SOY ROSA GARCIA
LEMOS Y VENGO DEL CAMPO. BUENA
VISTA Y DIGO NØ A LA PROPUESTA.
GRACIAS HOLA. BUENOS DIAS. MY
NAME IS JOSE ORTIZ AVALOS.
VENGO. REPRESENTATION DE TODOS
MIS COMPANEROS. PRESOS Y
PODIAMOS AYUDA PARA QUÊ NOS
APOYANDO Y ESTAMOS EN CONTRA DE
LA LEY. VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS GRACIAS. YO SOY GERARDO.
VENGO DE BUENA VISTA. NO ESTOY
DE ACUERDO CON LÀ CON LA LEY.
GRACIAS, SENORA. YES, MY NAME IS
ANGELICA NARANJO, AND I'M
AGAINST THE PROPORTION OF AB
2240. HELP US NOT TO OPEN IT
YEARLY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY BUENOS
DIAS. MY NAME IS GENOVEVA
NARANJO. VENGO DEL CAMPO DE LA
NG¯ÜI. ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LA
PROPOSITION 22. CUARENTA.
GRACIAS. GRACIAS, SENORA. BUENOS
DIAS. GALVAN Y VENGO DEL CAMPO
DE PARLIER. ESTOY EN CONTRA DE
LA PROPOSITION 22. CUARENTA.
GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. SOY BERTA
GUERRA. VENGO EL CAMPITO
MIGRATORIO PARA LEER Â.
TAMBIÉN. ESTOY EN CONTRA LA
PROPUESTA. VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS POR BUENOS DIAS. ME
NOMBRE ES EVANGELINA PIMENTEL DE
BUSTOS. VENGO REPRESENTANDO A
NOVENTA FAMILIAS DEL CAMPO DE
PARLIER. ESTE ESTAMOS EN CONTRA
DE LA PROPUESTA VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA TRAIGO CONMIGO. CARTAS
DE MIS COMPANEROS Y FIRMAS C¯
AQUI LO AVALON OKAY. SI PUEDES
PUEDES. THAT LÀ A LA SENORA. AHI
ES LA ENCARGADA DE LA DE LA
AUDIENCIA. SI GRACIAS. SI SI
PUEDES ESPERAR UN MOMENTITO.
VAMOS A TOMAR. UN POCO DE
ACCION. THIS. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A BREAK RIGHT NOW SO THAT
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
HERE. CABALLERO HERE. JONES.
ASHBY. BECKER. BECKER HERE.
BRADFORD. CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE.
WAHAB HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE CAN START TAKING ACTION ON
THIS. SO. SI. SI, SENORA. ESTAS
DISCULPA? BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME
IS CECILIA CALDERON. VENGO EL
CAMPO. HA NIELSEN DE D¯ÚI. ESTOY
ENCONTRAR LA VEINTIDOS VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA POR LA RAZONES DE C¯.
VA A SER MUCHO DESCONTROL PARA
TODOS NUESTROS FAMILIAS ESTÁ
VIENDO AFECTADOS LA SALUD POR
SABER. QUÉ ES LO C¯ VA A PASAR Y
A NUESTROS HIJOS EN LAS ESCUELAS
ENTENDEMOS? GRACIAS, GRACIAS,
SENOR. BUENOS DIAS. YO VENGO DEL
LICCARDO NIELSEN NÓI YO TÔI EN
CONTRA DE ESTA LEY. CUARENTA
GRACIAS, GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS,
JUAN ESPINOSA. YO ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE LA CUENTA, POR FAVOR.
GRACIAS. ONLY LET FOLKS IN THERE.
OKAY. BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES
HERIBERTO PEREZ EN CONTRA DE LA
SENORA. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. ME
NOMBRE ES MARTINA PANTOJA. ESTOY
EN CONTRA DE LA LEY. VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA. GRACIAS, SENORA.
BUENOS DIAS. ME RODOLFO CANELA Y
ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA
ÁP CUARENTA Y BIEN. GRACIAS
HELLO. MY NAME IS GABRIEL
PARGETER. I'M HERE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE FIRST
UNITARIAN UNIVERSALIST CHURCH OF
STOCKTON. AND WE ARE AGAINST AB
2240. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS REVEREND
MATT PASTOR VÌ MORRELL. I'M THE
MINISTER FOR THE FIRST UNITARIAN
UNIVERSALIST CHURCH OF STOCKTON.
I'M HERE WITH THE WESTERN FARM
WORKERS FROM STOCKTON, YUBA CITY
AND SANTA CRUZ, AND I'M HERE TO
URGE YOU TO VOTE AGAINST AB
2240. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD.
HOLA. MY NAME IS ERICA. ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA A
CUARENTA. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS.
MY NAME IS MARIO GUTIERREZ.
ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. GRACIAS
HOLA. BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES
BERTA MARTINEZ. Y ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA A
CUARENTA. MUCHAS GRACIAS. BUENOS
DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES VITORINO
MARTINEZ. Y ESTOY EN CONTRA DE
LA PROPUESTA CUARENTA. GRACIAS,
SENOR. BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES
MAYRA AVILA. Y ESTOY EN CONTRA
DE LA PROPUESTA CUARENTA. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE
ES MORALES Y ESTOY ESTÁ EN
CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA CUARENTA.
GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE
ES KARINA AVILA. SOY TRABAJADORA
MIGRANTE ESTÁ. ESTOY EN CONTRA
IN LA DE LA VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE
ES MARIA MENDEZ Y ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE ESTA PROPUESTA. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. GRACIAS, SENORA. BUENOS
DIAS. NOMBRE ES MARTIN AVILA.
ESTOY EN CONTRA DE VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA, SENORA. GRACIAS GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY. I'M SALUD
CORTEZ. I AM AGAINST AB 2240.
THANK YOU. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME
IS YESENIA. ESTOY EN CONTRA DE
LA PROPUESTA AB 22 CUARENTA.
GRACIAS, GRACIAS. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS AURELIA PEREZ, AND I
AM AGAINST AB 2240. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS ALICIA
MOSQUEDA AND I'M AGAINST AB
2240. THANK YOU. BUENOS DIAS. MY
NAME IS JOSEPHINE LA LUNA. ESTOY
EN CONTRA DE LA PROPOSITION AB
22 CUARENTA. GRACIAS SENORA.
BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS MARIA
GUADALUPE RODRIGUEZ. Y ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE LA AB VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA. GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS.
MY NAME IS ALICIA LEMUS. ESTOY
CONTRA DE LA VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
VERONICA VIVEROS. Y ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE LA CUARENTA. GRACIAS.
GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE
ES ESTRELLA LEMUS Y ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA AB 22
CUARENTA. MUCHAS GRACIAS. HI.
GOOD MORNING. I'M FROM SIERRA LA
FOUNDATION. MY NAME IS DAPHNE
RODRIGUEZ, AND I'M ALSO AGAINST
AB 2240. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I'M HERE WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. MY NAME
IS MONICA GARCIA ORTEGA AND I AM
AGAINST AB 2240. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS MIGUEL GARIBAY. I'M FROM
RTC THREE. IN FRENCH CAMP. I AM
AGAINST AB 2240. THANK YOU. SEE
YOU. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
JUAN LEMOS. VÆ NGUYEN EL CAMPO
ORTEZ C3. ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LA
OPOSICION VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS HOLA. MY NAME IS FABIAN
CALDERON. BIÂU EN EL CAMPO 43.
ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LA
PROPOSITION VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
DARIO RAMIREZ Y SOY SECRETARIO
REPRESENTANTE DEL CAMPO NAZARIAN.
TENEMOS LA CUARENTA. GRACIAS
BUENOS DIAS. MI NOMBRE ES
FERNANDO SERRATO DEL CAMPO, 63
Â EN CONTRA DE LA 22 CUARENTA.
GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. YO SOY
MARIA ESQUIVEL. VENGO DEL CAMPO
DE LA NIELSEN. YO VENGO EN
CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA.
VEINTIDOS. CUARENTA GRACIAS.
MUCHAS GRACIAS. ALICIA SOTO. NÓ.
LA PROPUESTA VEINTIDOS. CUARENTA
GRACIAS. MARIA MENCHACA.
RESIDENT DE NIELSEN NÓ A LA
CUENTA. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS, MY
NAME IS JOSE VERA. VENGO DEL
LODI DE LA NIELSEN A VENGO A
CONTRA DE LA PROPUESTA A 22
CUARENTA. GRACIAS ME NOMBRE ES
BRENDA. FAVELA. VENGO DEL CAMPO.
HA NIELSEN Y ESTOY EN CONTRA DE
LA 22. CUARENTA GRACIAS. BUENOS
DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES GUADALUPE
PEREZ. ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LA
FUENTE DEL CAMPO. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS EVELYN CORTEZ, AND I DON'T
AGREE WITH THE LAW. B 2240.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUENOS
DIAS. MY NAME IS MARICELA
CORTEZ, VENGO EN LA ENCONTRE DE
LA PROPOSITION 22. CUARENTA DE
CAMPO. GRACIAS, GRACIAS. BUENOS
DIAS. MY NAME IS ANDREA LUNA.
VENGO DEL CAMPO. NIELSEN. VENGO
A CONTRA LA A POSITION DE LA
QUINTA DOS CUARENTA. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
MIGUEL ANGEL. VÌ. TENGO
REPRESENTANDO EL CAMPO ORTEZ.
THE FRENCH CAMP Â QUISIÉRAMOS
C¯ AN ECHO IN TODAS ESTAS
PERSONAS. IBAN LA LÀ LA VÀ PARA
TODAS ESTAS PERSONAS. CUARENTA.
GRACIAS. MUCHAS GRACIAS. JOSÉ
MARIA SILVIA TORRES. INOCENCIO.
VENGO DEL CAMPO DOS FRENCH CAMP.
VENGO ENCONTRE DE LA LEY
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA SENORA
GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE
ES JESUS Y VIVO EN EL FISHCAMP Y
VENGO. ENCONTRE DE LA
PROPOSITION A.B. VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS.
YO SOY MARIA PRADO Y VENGO DE LA
FRIDGECAM Y ESTOY EN CONTRA DE
LA VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. GRACIAS.
EN DÍAS. YO SOY JESUS. SORIA.
VENGO DEL CAMPO. DOS Y ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE LA DE LA CUARENTA.
GRACIAS. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS. ME
NOMBRE DE LUIS PEREZ CORTEZ.
VENGO CONTRA LA CUARENTA. VENGO
DE FRENCH CAMP. EL CAMPO. TRES
GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS NÚMERO
ROBERTO PEREZ CORTEZ. VENGO DEL
ARTISTA FRENCH CAMP Y TAMBIÉN
TENGO EN CONTRA DE LA FUENTE DOS
CUARENTA. GRACIAS BUENOS DIAS.
MY NAME IS ARMANDO PEREZ. EVEN
WHEN CONTRA TAMBIÉN DE LA
CUARENTA. SO THE FRENCH CAMP.
GRACIAS MY NAME IS RAFAEL. ESTOY
ENCONTRE DE LA. VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA. GRACIAS. GRACIAS GOOD
MORNING, COUNCIL MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS SCOTT MINOTT. I'M FROM
STOCKTON, CALIFORNIA. RETIRED
TEACHER. AND I WOULD WANTED TO
REPORT TO YOU THAT WE JUST HAD A
PHONE CALL FROM REPRESENTING 45
FARM WORKERS FROM ORANGE COUNTY
THAT ARE ALSO AGAINST AB 2240.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, I
APPRECIATE THAT. CAN YOU TELL
THEM ABOUT THE FINES? I GOT IT
WEDNESDAY. MY NAME IS GUILLERMO
PEREZ. VENGO IN CONTRA DE LA
PROPOSITION VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
GRACIAS, SENOR. BUENOS DIAS. MY
NAME IS DAHLIA CORTEZ Y VENGO EN
CONTRA DE LA AB VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA Y VENGO DEL CAMPO DE
LODI. GRACIAS. MUCHAS GRACIAS.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU READ IN
SPANISH. I'M GOING TO SAY WHAT I
SAID EARLIER IN SPANISH. HAVE WE
SEEN ALL OKAY. AND THEY CAME.
THEY SAID THEY CAME. AGRADECER A
TODAS LAS PERSONAS C¯ VINIERON A
SU TESTIMONIO. ESTE ES, COMO
EXPLIQUÉ EN INGLÉS ANTES. ESTE
ES EL COMITÉ FISCALIA Þ SI
QUIERE DECIR C¯ SI UNA PROPUESTA
TIENE ALGO C¯ VER O UN CARILLO
ALGO C¯ VER CON DINERO VÀ KHÓ EL
ESTADO VIENE A ESTE ESTE COMITÉ
Y TENEMOS Þ ESTAMOS ENCARGADO DE
DETERMINAR CUALES PROPUESTAS VAN
A SEGUIR Y EQUALS VAN A QUEDAR
AQUI Y MUERAN. SO AHORA LO C¯
VAMOS A HACER CON CON TODO O CÁC
TODOS LOS LAS PROPUESTAS C¯
TENEMOS ES BÀN, VAMOS A MANDALO
A SUSPENSION O SI VAMOS A
SUSPENDER LOS ESO QUIERE DECIR
C¯ NOS DA LA OPORTUNIDAD DE
DÉTERMINER CUAL ES DE LOS MAS DE
THREE CIENTOS PROPUESTAS C¯
TIENE EL ASAMBLEÍSTA. LAS
ASAMBLEÍSTA CUALES VAN A SEGUIR
Y CUALES VAN A TERMINAR SO SU
TESTIMONIO AHORA ES MUY, MUY
IMPORTANTE B¢O C¯ SABER C¯ VAMOS
A SUSPENDER. ESTE CASO, JUNTO
CON LOS DEMAS PARA RIVAS LO CON
MAS DETALLE Â IN IN LA SEMANA
QUÊ O NO ESTA SEMANA, VAMOS A
PASAR LAS PROPUESTAS QUÊ QUÊ ES
DE QUALIFICATION. SO IN ESTA
MOMENT, LO C¯ VAMOS A HACER IS
TOMAR ACTION PARA PONER LO IN
SUSPENSION. PERO QUERIA DE SER
MUCHISIMAS GRACIAS POR SU
TESTIMONIO SE C¯ PARA ESTAR
AQUI. HOY TUVIERON C¯ SALIR MUY
MUY TEMPRANO EN LA MANANA. UNO Y
DOS C¯ USTEDES PIDIERON EL DIA
DE TRABAJO. YO YO ENTIENDO
PERFECTAMENTE BIEN Â SI ME
CONOCES YO SOY UN CABALLERO. YO
FUI LA ALCALDESA DE LA CIUDAD DE
SALINAS. PERO AHORA REPRESENTA
AL CENTRAL. SO NO, NO PODEMOS
TOMAR PREGUNTAS. PERO VAMOS A
SABER DEL THE DEL EL
DEPARTAMENTO DE FISCALIA. EL
COSTO VAMOS A VER SI TIENEN UN
ARCHIVO Y LUEGO ESTE COMITÉ
VAMOS A DAR A ESTA PROPUESTA A
SUSPENSION OKAY. NO MAS EXPLICAR
EL PROCESO PORQUE ES UN POCO
DIFICIL ENTENDER EXACTAMENTE LO
C¯. VAMOS A HACER Y SI SIGUE LA
PROPUESTA O SI SI EN EL FUTURO
LO DEJAMOS SALIR VA A TENER LA
OPORTUNIDAD DE SEGUIR PELEANDO
LO Þ PUEDE SER C¯ MUERA EN ESTE
ESTÁ COMITÉ. PERO NO PUEDO DECIR
EN ESTE MOMENT, OKAY, ESO ES EL
PROCESO OKAY. SI SI SENOR. QUÉ
BUENO. GRACIAS A LA FOR ME. NO I
KNOW SI. YEAH YEAH. ES UNA
ORGANIZACION MUY GRANDE. OKAY
MUY BIEN. VAMOS A PASAR EL
DEPARTAMENTO DE FISCALIA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
OKAY ASI C¯ NÓI ARCHIVO. SO
VAMOS A SEGUIR. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. THIS IS, SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT, IF
THERE IS NO QUESTIONS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE WILL MOVE THIS TO
SUSPENSE. MUCHAS GRACIAS. A
TODOS. OKAY. A BEFORE. YES. SO
SALIR ESTE ES UN MEMENTO DE
HACERLO PORQUE ES, VAMOS A
SEGUIR CON CON LA AGENDA. MUCHAS
GRACIAS, SO JUST TO BE CLEAR, AT
AB 2240 WAS MOVED TO SUSPENSE
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO AB
FOUR, WHICH WE HEARD EARLIER.
AND THAT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB FOUR WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AS
WELL. MR. TÌM. MR. ZUBIATE YEAH,
OKAY. YOU CAN REMIND ME HIS HE
HAS A BR. YEAH, YEAH. HE'S HERE.
YES. I'M LOOKING FOR HIS OKAY ON
FOR HOURS. I'M GOING TO. YEAH
OKAY. WE'LL GIVE HIM A SECOND TO
EXIT THE ROOM. YES. TÍNH WAS
HERE FIRST. HE WAS HERE FIRST.
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THAT. TWO
MEMBERS. WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO, I
THINK HE WAS HERE FIRST. WHAT IS
FRENCH? YEAH, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON IN THE AGENDA AND WE'RE
JUMPING HERE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TÍNH IS HERE, SO WE'LL INVITE
HIM TO COME FORWARD. AND, JUST
FOR THE COMMITTEE'S SAKE, I
EXPLAINED IN SPANISH WHAT I
EXPLAINED EARLIER IN THE MORNING
IN ENGLISH. AND SO, THAT WAY
THEY KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS IS.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TÍNH AB 1777.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I'M
PRESENTING AB 1777, WHICH IS, MY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE BILL. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS. AS YOU KNOW,
IN SAN FRANCISCO, AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES HAVE BEEN ON THE ROAD
FOR QUITE A WHILE. AND GIVEN OUR
EXPERIENCE, WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF SITUATIONS WHERE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES HAVE, BROKEN THE LAW.
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY DRIVEN THEIR
VEHICLES WITH PASSENGERS INTO
LIVE POLICE SITUATIONS, LIVE
FIRE SITUATIONS, WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS SET UP A PROCESS WHERE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE COMPANIES
WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
CURRENTLY, THERE IS NO WAY FOR A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER TO SITE
AN AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE COMPANY
THE WAY WE WOULD BE SITED IF YOU
OR I WERE SPEEDING OR RAN A STOP
SIGN. SO THIS. THIS SETS UP A
PROCESS WHERE WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HOLD AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
ACCOUNTABLE. THERE WILL BE A
DEDICATED HOTLINE FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS TO BE ABLE TO TALK
TO. SOMEBODY SHOULD THEY NEED TO
IMMOBILIZE OR MOVE THAT VEHICLE.
ALSO, THE THIS WILL ALLOW A
PROCESS TO SET UP TWO WAY
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE CAR
AND A PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER
SHOULD THERE NEED TO BE
COMMUNICATION TO STOP THE
VEHICLE OR TO MOVE THE VEHICLE?
ALSO, THERE WILL BE SPEAKING TO
THE FISCAL PART OF IT, IF YOU
COULD GET THE FISCAL. SURE. I'M
NOT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FISCAL
PART OF IT IS. THIS DOES, ENJOY
A DUE PASS RECOMMENDATION. SO
VERY, VERY GOOD. KIND OF. THE
LONGER YOU GO ON IT, WE'RE
LIKELY TO. YES. VERY GOOD. I'M
HAPPY TO, WITH THAT RESPECT, I
VOTE ON AB SEVEN VERY WISE MEN.
YES, IS THERE ANY. THANK YOU FOR
THE NUDGE. APPRECIATE IT.
ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? NO CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO, AS WELL AS THE
SAN FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY, BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD IN
SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, YOU MAY CONCLUDE Ó.
JUST ASK FOR REPO. VERY GOOD.
THIS, THIS, BILL HAS A Dð PASS
MOTION. DO I HAVE A MOTION MOVED
BY BY SENATOR BRADFORD, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. JONES. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE CIERTO.
CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE
VOTE IS 6 TO 0. 6 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE TO WAIT FOR JOE. DID YOU
WANT A PIECE OF. OH WE DO
ACTUALLY WE WILL PLACE IT ON
CALL FOR SENATOR JONES I DO
APOLOGIZE, I GOT TOO EXCITED
THERE, WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE
ON TO AB 2498 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF BR. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. YEAH,
EXACTLY. AND AGAIN, FISCAL.
YEAH. THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS,
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2498,
WHICH IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR
BOTH THE PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS AND
THE LGBTQ CAUCUS. THIS BILL IS
JOINTLY AUTHORED WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AND
COAUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIZ AND LEE. ONE OF THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE AND COMPASSIONATE
WAYS OF REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IS PREVENTION,
EMPOWERING PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY HOUSED TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES. AB 2498. THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING SECURITY ACT,
WHICH IS THE PRODUCT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AND I AND MR.
ALANIS MERGING SIMILAR BILLS,
WILL INCREASE HOUSING SECURITY
BY PROVIDING HOUSING SUBSIDIES
TO ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS AND
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
ESTABLISH A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM FOR UP TO EIGHT COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND PROVIDE AN
AMOUNT NECESSARY TO COVER THE
PORTION OF A PERSON'S HOUSING
NOT TO EXCEED EITHER. A ONE TIME
$2,000 SUBSIDY OR AN ONGOING
SUBSIDY OF UP TO $2,000 PER
MONTH FOR THE DURATION OF THE
TWO YEAR PILOT PROGRAM. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STATES
THAT THIS BILL CREATES GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE BILLIONS,
WHICH WE DISAGREE WITH IT. I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THIS BILL SHALL BECOME OPERATIVE
ONLY UPON APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE OF SUFFICIENT FUNDS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM. THE BILL DOES NOT
CREATE SOME KIND OF STATEWIDE
ENTITLEMENT THAT WILL COST
BILLIONS. IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL
IN ACHIEVING AN APPROPRIATION,
IT WILL COST THE AMOUNT THAT
ULTIMATELY IS ALLOCATED TO THE
EIGHT COUNTY PILOT PROGRAM. THE
BILL CREATES A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT HAS SPECIFIC CRITERIA THAT
ENVISIONS THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND NONPROFITS WILL SUBMIT
PROPOSALS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. WE WORKED WITH, AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
TECHNICAL INPUT ABOUT HOW TO
STRUCTURE THE BILL TO ADMINISTER
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT ARE
COSTED OUT AND LIMITED IN COST
THROUGH THE GRANTS THAT ARE
ISSUED. WHEN WE WERE DEVISING
THE CRITERIA AND OVERSIGHT FOR
THE BILL, WE CRAFTED IT AS A
PILOT PROGRAM AND ENVISIONED
FUNDING OF BETWEEN 100 AND $200
MILLION. FINALLY, IN PART IN
PART AS A RESULT OF BUDGET SUB
CHAIR FIVE, ASSEMBLYWOMAN
QUIRK-SILVA. ADVOCACY. THE
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE $1 BILLION
ALLOCATED THROUGH THE HOMELESS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM, H HAP THAT
IS INTENDED TO FUND PROGRAMS TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE NEW
BILLS WERE NOT FUNDED THROUGH
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR, THE H HAP
CRITERIA WOULD NEED TO BE
MODIFIED TO ALLOW A PORTION OF
THE FUNDING TO BE TAPPED, SO WE
INTEND TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BUDGET
AND LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP TO
DEVELOP SUPPORT FOR ABOUT 100 TO
200 MILLION TO BE ALLOCATED FROM
THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR'S H HAP
ALLOCATION TO THIS IMPORTANT
PILOT PROGRAM. IN CLOSING,
HOUSING SUBSIDY PROGRAMS PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN REDUCING
HARDSHIP, IMPROVING HEALTH AND
PROMOTING ECONOMIC STABILITY,
AND CONTRIBUTING TO POTENTIAL
COST SAVINGS, IN THE FUTURE, I'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA FOR HER PARTNERSHIP
AND HER AMAZING ADVOCACY FOR THE
STATE TO MAKE MEANINGFUL STEPS
REGARDING HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION AND FOR HER WORK
LEADING ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
FIVE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD, IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
HI. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS.
PRISCILLA, KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD. IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. KIM LEWIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, CRAIG PULSIFER ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, BECCA KRAMER, ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND SUPPORT. GREAT CAROLINE
GRINDER ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
$797,000. GENERAL FUND AND FOUR
POSITIONS IN THE 20, 26, 27 AND
ONGOING FOR STATE OPERATIONS TO
ADMINISTER THE PILOT PROGRAM.
FINANCE. NOTES THAT DEPENDING ON
THE SCOPE OF THE PROGRAM, THIS
BILL LIKELY CREATES GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES IN THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR TWO
YEARS TO PROVIDE HOUSING
SUBSIDIES TO ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS. THE STATE PROVIDED
A TOTAL OF 4.5 BILLION, OF WHICH
1.6 BILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO APPROXIMATELY 377,000
HOUSEHOLDS THROUGH THE STATE
ADMINISTERED EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR THESE
REASONS, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES NEW
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET. OKAY SEEING
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS,
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. YEAH, THE ONLY THING
I'LL SAY IS THAT THIS IS NOT
SOME OPEN ENDED, HIT ON THE
BUDGET. IT WOULD REQUIRE AN
APPROPRIATION AND SINCE IT'S A
PILOT PROGRAM, IT WILL COST WHAT
IS APPROPRIATED FOR THE PROGRAM
PLUS THE PLUS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS THAT I THINK HE'S
INDICATED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2498 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA.
AND THE NEXT UP IS AB 544 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? BECCA KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER IN
SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT AN OPPOSITION? CLIFTON
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE SOLANO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE? DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE. THE SECRETARY OF STATE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF $155,000.
GENERAL FUND IN 2025, 26 AND
13,000 GENERAL FUND AND 20 2627
THROUGH TO 20 2930 TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL. ADDITIONALLY, THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF $900,000 ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN 20 2526 TO
PROVIDE GRANTS FOR THREE
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS
TO IMPROVE VOTER PARTICIPATION
IN JAIL FACILITIES. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL MAY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES A NEW PROGRAM OR HIGHER
LEVEL OF SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED
BY LOCAL AGENCIES. ONCE AGAIN,
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN 2024
BUDGET AND MAY IMPOSE STATE
REIMBURSABLE COSTS ON THE THREE
PILOT PROGRAM COUNTIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 544 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. OKAY, MOVING ON TO AB
653 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE DOZIER. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SACRAMENTO
HOUSING AND REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY, AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HOUSING AUTHORITIES. KAYA IS A
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER 75 PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE ARE INDEPENDENT
PUBLIC ENTITIES WHICH OPERATE
UNDER FEDERAL REGULATIONS FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT, KAYA AND THE
PHAS PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT MEETS THE HOUSING CRISIS
FOR PEOPLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORING
ORGANIZATION INTENT TO ENHANCE
THE UTILIZATION OF VOUCHER
PROGRAM. HOWEVER, WE BELIEVE
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT ALIGN
WITH THE GOAL OF ACHIEVING THAT
OBJECTIVE EFFECTIVELY AND
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL AS
IT IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED. IT IS.
IT IS TO AUTHORIZE GRANT FUNDING
AND TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
PROGRAM APPLICANTS SEEKING
HOUSING THROUGH A HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHER. BUT UNLIKE MOST GRANT
PROGRAMS, THE REGULATORY AND
REPORTING ASPECTS OF AB 65653
WOULD APPLY TO ALL CALIFORNIA
HOUSING AUTHORITIES, WHETHER
THEY APPLY FOR THE GRANT,
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM OR NOT.
THIS TAKES AWAY FROM THE
PRECIOUS TIME THAT WE HAVE, AND
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT ALREADY
STRUGGLES ADMINISTRATIVELY WITH
NOT GETTING ENOUGH FUNDING FROM
HUD. IF STAFF ARE SPENDING TIME
DOING ALL OF THE REPORTING
THAT'S REQUIRED UNDER 653, THEY
DON'T HAVE THE TIME NECESSARY TO
REALLY FOCUS ON HELPING OUR
FAMILIES GET INTO HOUSING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THERE IS A
VERY EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT HUD
HAS ADMINISTERED CALLED THE
EMERGENCY HOUSING VOUCHER
PROGRAM, THAT EMPLOYS ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT 653 HAS DONE. AND I
JUST WANT TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUE
PATRICIA WELLS, WHO IS THE CEO
OF THE OAKLAND HOUSING
AUTHORITY, JUST TALK ABOUT THE
SUCCESS OF THAT PROGRAM. SO, YOU
KNOW WHAT? THIS IS REALLY NOT A
POLICY DISCUSSION. THIS IS A
FISCAL DISCUSSION. SO WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, I HATE TO CUT
ANYBODY OFF, BUT, IT WE'RE JUST
FOCUSING ON THE FISCAL. AND THIS
IS GOING TO GO TO SUSPENSE. IT'S
NOT GETTING OUT TODAY. SO IF YOU
COULD JUST KIND OF WRAP UP AND,
I APPRECIATE THE, THE DETAIL
WITH WHICH YOU COULD PROBABLY GO
INTO INTO HOUSING, WHICH IS
COMPLICATED, BUT IT'S, IT'S A IF
IT DOESN'T ALIGN WITH FEDERAL,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THEN
THAT'S THAT, THAT'S REALLY THE
FOCUS BECAUSE THIS IS STATE
MONEY THAT WE'RE PUTTING OUT
THERE. SO APPRECIATE THAT. CAN I
ASK ONE QUESTION. FISCAL OF
COURSE. YEAH. CAN WE WAIT UNTIL
WELL, ACTUALLY GO AHEAD. THIS
PARTICULAR SPEAKER, SORRY. I'LL
BE QUICK AND BRIEF, BECAUSE THIS
COMMITTEE IS REALLY OF THE BILL, IS IT
IS PART OF YOUR, CONCLUSION IN
YOUR ANALYSIS OF THE BILL THAT
FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT, FOR
AGENCIES LIKE YOURS THAT ARE
PROVIDING HOUSING FOR COUNTIES,
THAT IT WOULD INCREASE OR REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF FEDERAL VOUCHERS
THAT WE HAVE TO GIVE FUNDING TO
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM, IT WOULD
REDUCE IN TERMS OF THE ABILITY
FOR US TO RESPOND TO OUR LOCAL
HOUSING. OFFICIALS. IN OTHER
WORDS, WE COULD LOSE FEDERAL
VOUCHERS AND THEREFORE HAVE
FEWER RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
RIGHT BECAUSE THERE'S A
CONTRADICTION BETWEEN IF THERE'S
A STATE AND A FEDERAL, AND
FEDERAL IS REALLY WHAT WE ANSWER
TO. OKAY, GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD QUESTION
AND APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. YES PATRICIA
WELLS, CEO OF THE OAKLAND
HOUSING AUTHORITY, ALSO A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT OFFICIALS,
RESPECTFULLY, IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL, THE FISCAL IMPACT,
CHAIR, WOULD BE THAT HOUSING
AUTHORITIES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
DO WORK. THAT IS UNFUNDED, AS
WOULD THE STATE HCD HUD, THE
AUTHORIZING ENTITY FOR HCV
PROGRAM, UNDERSTOOD THIS Dð THE
ISSUANCE OF THE EMERGENCY
HOUSING VOUCHERS, OF WHICH
75,000 OF THEM WERE DISTRIBUTED
NATIONALLY. HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
WE SUCCESSFULLY LEASED UP IN 1.5
IN 1 YEAR AND A HALF, AND WE DID
THAT BECAUSE THERE WAS $3,500
PER UNIT ALLOCATED FOR THOSE
COSTS, SUCH AS SERVICES FOR THE
CLIENTS, SERVICES FOR THE
LANDLORDS AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS, SO THAT PROVEN SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM INDICATES THAT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR OUR
HOUSING AUTHORITIES, THE IMPACT
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT ON FISCAL
LOSS AS WELL AS AVAILABLE
VOUCHER LOSS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE SONOMA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THOMAS FRANCO ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION IN OPPOSITION TO AB
653, WE BELIEVE THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS APPROPRIATELY
STATES THE FISCAL IMPACT ON BOTH
THE LOCAL AGENCY AND THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. ERIC JOHNSON,
REPRESENTING THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CRUZ. AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, DOCTOR TANYA. LET'S
HIÂU CEO OF THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. JESSICA
COHEN, HOUSING AUTHORITY OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN JOAQUIN. I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF OCCUPANCY AND
HOUSING COMPLIANCE, AND I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. ROB
FREDERICKS, HOUSING AUTHORITY OF
THE CITY OF SANTA BARBARA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
FOR THE REASONS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY STATED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. RICARDO
TORRES WITH THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY OF THE CITY OF SAN
BUENAVENTURA AND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, SENATOR CABALLERO.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
PRESTON PRINCE, I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY HOUSING AUTHORITY,
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
REDEVELOPMENT OFFICIALS, AND
OFFICER OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF CAJA AND
THE. WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. KIARA ROSS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF GLENDALE
AND IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. STEPHEN STANZLER WITH
BROWNSTEIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGAL RURAL, LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION,
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING, HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONAL HOUSING LAW PROJECT,
AND THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY, THE CO-SPONSORS OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WAS THAT IN SUPPORT?
YES YES. OKAY. ALL RIGHTY. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
OR SINCE WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT TO
IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IS NOT
ABLE TO PROVIDE A SPECIFIC COST
ESTIMATE AT THIS TIME. HOWEVER,
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES INDICATE
SEVERAL MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO
ESTABLISH AND ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTES THAT THIS BILL
CREATES GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES OF UP TO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
HCD TO PROVIDE PUBLIC HOUSING
AUTHORITY PROGRAM GRANT FUNDING.
ADDITIONALLY FUNDING
APPROPRIATED FOR THE PROGRAM
CANNOT BE USED FOR HCD'S
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS, WHICH WILL
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS. THEREFORE,
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT CREATES GENERAL FUND
COSTS AND COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THANK YOU, SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 653 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 799 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? REBECCA
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE. CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS ESTIMATES A NEED
FOR TWO POSITIONS AND $665,000.
GENERAL FUND IN 2025, 26, AND
$349,000 GENERAL FUND IN 20
2627, AS WELL AS ONGOING
PRESSURE TO COLLECT FISCAL AND
OUTCOME DATA FROM STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES.
FINANCE ONCE AGAIN OPPOSES THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET ACT. VERY GOOD.
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 799 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 863 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? GREG
HERNER, ON BEHALF OF THE CARPET
CUSHION COUNCIL, I THINK WHAT,
IN REGARDS TO THE FISCAL ISSUE,
ANYTIME YOU PUT A FEE ON A
PRODUCT, YOU'RE GOING TO
INCREASE COSTS. THE STATE IS A
MAJOR LANDLORD, A MAJOR TENANT
IN THE STATE, REPLACING ANY OF
THE MATERIALS IS GOING TO DRIVE
UP STATE COSTS. AS FAR AS
CUSHION GOES, CUSHION IS NOT
EXCLUSIVE TO CARPET. IT IS
ALMOST 100% RECYCLED MATERIAL
AND THERE'S NO REASON TO PROVIDE
BRING CUSHION INTO THE CARPET
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO SUBSIDIZE
THE CARPET RECYCLING PROGRAM, WE
RECYCLE FOAM FROM AUTOMOTIVE,
FROM MATTRESS RECYCLING, FROM
MATTRESS PRODUCTION, FROM
SPECIALIZED PACKAGING. SO ALL
IT'S GOING TO DO IS INCREASE
COST TO THE STATE FOR ANOTHER
LAYER OF MATERIAL. THAT'S
ALREADY MEETING, MEETING THE
CIRCULARITY GOALS THAT THE STATE
WANTS TO PUT IN PLACE. SO
THERE'S NO REASON TO PUT AN
ADDITIONAL FEE ON IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSED? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE.
SO SEEING NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB 863 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2223 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAR
CURRY WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? SIR, I FEEL BAD,
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. RAND
MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF THE US HEMP
ROUNDTABLE, THE FISCAL IMPACT
THAT'S NOT ACKNOWLEDGED IN THE
ANALYSIS IS THE FACT THAT MANY
BUSINESSES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
FOLLOWING THE RULES THAT WE SET
FORTH THREE YEARS AGO WILL BE
PUT OUT OF BUSINESS BECAUSE
THEY'LL NO LONGER BE ALLOWED TO
MANUFACTURE THE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE SELLING TO CONSUMERS. NOW,
THAT WILL MEAN A SUBSTANTIAL
LOSS OF SALES TAX REVENUE,
EMPLOYEE TAX REVENUE AND OTHER
LOCAL TAXES. IF THIS BILL WERE
TO GO INTO EFFECT, AND IN ITS
CURRENT FORM, MOST OF THE BILL
IS PERFECTLY FINE. IT'S A GOOD
BILL, BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE GOOD ACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT BEING HARMED
WHILE WE TRY TO GET RID OF THE
BAD ACTORS. APPRECIATE YOUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MADAM CHAIR, MY NAME
IS PATRICK SHATZER. I'M THE
REGULATORY AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
SUN MED. YOUR CBD STORE WITH THE
LARGEST BRICK AND MORTAR CBD
RETAILER IN THE US. WE HAVE 18
LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
ARE SET TO CLOSE IF THIS BILL
GOES THROUGH, FOR THE FISCAL
IMPACT, THIS BILL JEOPARDIZES
$250 MILLION IN SALES TAX
REVENUE AND OVER 41,000 JOBS.
OUR STORES ALONE, SINCE EARLY
SINCE OCTOBER 2021, HAVE
GENERATED $11.5 MILLION. PAYING
APPROXIMATELY LIKE 410,000 IN
SALES TAXES. THIS BILL IS A IS A
GOOD BILL, BUT THE LINE OF
INTOXICATION THAT IT DRAWS OF
THC IS SO LOW THAT IT DOESN'T
ALLOW NORMAL GENERAL WELLNESS
TO, TO SURVIVE, YOU'LL HEAR FROM
A FEW OF OUR STORE MEMBERS NOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAD. PATO, THREE LOCATIONS IN
NORTH BAY. I'M FROM PETALUMA,
CALIFORNIA, THIS WOULD
DEFINITELY HAVE AN IMPACT. IT
WOULD DEFINITELY CLOSE THE THREE
STORES I HAVE. WE DO $1.5
MILLION A YEAR IN TAX REVENUE,
AND THAT'S ALSO WOULD LOSE TEN
JOBS FROM STAFF MEMBERS. I THINK
IT'S A GREAT DEAL. WE DO NEED
REGULATIONS. WE DO NEED A CAP, I
WOULD SUPPORT LIKE AN EXCISE TAX
BECAUSE THERE IS NO ENFORCEMENT
AND IT'S ALWAYS HURT. THE GOOD
ACTORS AND THE BAD ACTORS WILL
ALWAYS EXIST. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SO, SO I DON'T NEED TO
HEAR THE GOOD BILL STUFF BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT HERE ON THE POLICY.
WE'RE HERE ON THE MONEY. SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR WE'RE
FOCUSING ON THE REVENUE. HI, MY
NAME IS ALLISON SCHMIDT. I'M
DISTRICT MANAGER FOR SUN MED,
YOUR CBD STORE. I HAVE THREE
LOCATIONS WITHIN THE BAY AREA.
THIS BILL WOULD RESULT IN MYSELF
AND MY TEN TEAM MEMBERS LOSING
OUR JOBS. AS I AM OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS LAUREN
LURCH. I AM AN OWNER OF YOUR CBD
STORE IN SUN MED. I HAVE FIVE
LOCATIONS HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. I WAS A
CUSTOMER FIRST USING SUN MED
PRODUCTS DUE TO PTSD FROM BEING
INVOLVED IN A MASS SHOOTING. I
AM SOMEONE THAT WOULD NOT SHOP
AT ANOTHER LOCATION FOR GENERIC
WELLNESS PRODUCTS LIKE THIS. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE I KNOW
WE WILL LOSE CUSTOMERS. WE'VE
DONE OVER $6 MILLION IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS ALL SALES WITH SALES
TAX, COUNTY YOU KNOW, PERMITS
AND I WILL LOSE 15 STAFF
MEMBERS. AND AS A MOTHER OF
THREE AND BEING THERE FOR OTHER
OTHER CLIENTS, WE NEED TO STAY
IN BUSINESS. THIS BILL WILL SHUT
DOWN OUR STORES. SO I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL RAMIREZ. I'M ONE OF THE
OWNERS OF A $52 MILLION FACILITY
BUILT DOWN IN LÀ TO SUPPORT THIS
INDUSTRY. WE HAVE OVER 100
EMPLOYEES, AND IF THIS BILL
PASSES, IT WILL SHUT DOWN OUR
FACILITY. WE ALSO REPRESENT AND
MAKE DRINKS FOR FOLKS LIKE
CHEECH AND CHONG, WE THINK THIS
IS I WANT TO CAÑADA THAT WE WANT
THIS AS A GOOD BILL, BUT, BUT,
YOU KNOW, FIVE MILLIGRAMS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO KEEP THIS BILL
OR, SORRY, THE, OUR INDUSTRY
ALIVE. AND THE 5% EXCISE TAX WE
SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS AND YOU'LL
YOU'LL HOPEFULLY THAT YOU'LL
RECEIVE THEM. BUT THE 5% EXCISE
TAX THAT WE'RE REQUESTING SHOULD
BRING IN ABOUT $200 MILLION THE
FIRST YEAR, WHICH WE NEED. IF IT
DOESN'T, IT'S GOING TO COST US
MORE THAN THAT IN ENFORCEMENT.
SO PLEASE, WE WOULD JUST REQUEST
YOU LOOK AT OUR AMENDMENTS AND
GO WITH THEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. KIM
CRAIG WITH ARC STRATEGIES ON
BEHALF OF CAN. WE ARE A PRODUCER
OF LOW DOSE HEMP BEVERAGES AND
FOR THE COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY
BEFORE ME, WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. OKAY. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB 2223 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
1198 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREYSON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1198?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE. ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, THIS
BILL RESULTS IN ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE RANGE OF 1.6
MILLION TO $2.4 MILLION ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN 20 2425 FOR
INCREASED WORKLOAD FOR THESE
REASONS, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
AS A RESULT, AN INCREASE ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET ACT. VERY
GOOD SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1198 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WE TOOK ALREADY TOOK UP AB 1777,
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB 2401 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
WEST DONNELLY WITH CLEANER FOR
KIDS.ORG SUPPORTING AB 2401 TING
ALONG WITH THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS FACTS, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS AND CA
SDCL GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION
SONOMA COUNTY YOUTH ACTION
COMMITTEE ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO
CARLSBAD DEMOCRATS, CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE AND THE NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE. THE STATE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL REQUIRES
$1.1 MILLION FROM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND AND FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS IN 2024, 25
AND ONGOING ONCE AGAIN, FINANCE
IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
THE RESULTS IN ONGOING
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
MULTIYEAR CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT WAS
ADOPTED AS PART OF THE 2024
BUDGET AGREEMENT. VERY GOOD,
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2401 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1859 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES COSTS OF
$690,000. GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
FIRST THREE YEARS AND $200,000
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO MODIFY
AND POPULATE THE CALIFORNIA
OVERDOSE SURVEILLANCE DASHBOARD.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ADDITIONALLY ANTICIPATES THIS
BILL LIKELY CREATES A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE OF
APPROXIMATELY $580,000. GENERAL
FUND FOR COUNTY CORONERS. THIS
ASSUMES AN AVERAGE COST OF
$10,000 ANNUALLY FOR 58
COUNTIES. TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL, AGAIN,
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT CREATES A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
AND CREATES OTHER GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. VERY GOOD. SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1859 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3080 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALANIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. DANNY CANDLE
KAISER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION,
AS WELL AS PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE, AS THE ANALYSIS
INDICATES, THE BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO COST CALIFORNIA
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS IN, STATE
FUNDED TRIAL COSTS. WE HAVE SEEN
AT LEAST EIGHT CASES IN OTHER
STATES, INCLUDING, WHICH ARE ALL
RELATED TO FIRST AMENDMENT
VIOLATIONS FILED AGAINST SIMILAR
AGE VERIFICATION LAWS. IN OTHER
STATES. WHILE THE TOTAL COSTS
ARE STILL UNKNOWN, WE KNOW THAT
IN FLORIDA ALONE, AS OF 2022,
THE COSTS WERE $10 MILLION JUST
IN THAT STATE ALONE AND ONGOING
FOR THAT COST. OR FOR THAT
STATE, WE NOTE THAT FEDERAL
LEGISLATION RELATED TO AGE
VERIFICATION IS UNDERWAY. AND,
WE WOULD URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
HOLD THIS BILL WHILE WE AWAIT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. AND NOT INVITE
ADDITIONAL SIGNIFICANT, COSTLY
LAWSUITS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BECCA KRAMER, MATTER.
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION, ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE?
PERMANENT FINANCE NÓ FILE.
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3080 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1864 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? MÁS
DONNELLY WITH CLEANER FOR KIDS
DOT ORG SUPPORTING AB 1864.
CONNOLLY, ALONG WITH THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS FACTS
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND CA
ESTÁ SEQUEL GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH. MOMS ADVOCATING
SUSTAINABILITY, YARD SMART,
MARIN SONOMA SAS STANDING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE CARLSBAD
DEMOCRATS, CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL, HEALTH AND
JUSTICE AND BEYOND. PESTICIDES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE. DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION ESTIMATES
COSTS OF $174,000 FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION FUND AND ONE
PERMANENT POSITION ONGOING TO
UPDATE REGULATIONS AND EVALUATE
COUNTY'S PESTICIDE USE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS RELATED TO
PESTICIDE APPLICATION NEAR
SCHOOL SITES. IN ADDITION,
REGULATIONS ALREADY CURRENTLY
REQUIRE PESTICIDE USE REPORTS TO
INCLUDE THE DAY AND TIME WHICH
PESTICIDE APPLICATION STARTS AND
ENDS. FURTHER, THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ALREADY PUBLISHES A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DIRECTORY
DIRECTORY PUBLICLY ON ITS
INTERNET WEBSITE, INCLUDING
PRIVATE SCHOOL LOCATION DATA.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN ADDITIONAL
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET, AND APPEARS TO BE
PARTIALLY DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING AUTHORITY THING. NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPEND
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1864 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 1893
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT OH GO AHEAD, HOLLY FROM
THE LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY, CALIFORNIA
SANDHILL PROPERTIES SPUR CIVIC
WILL AND CALIFORNIA YIMBY. THANK
YOU. BOB NAYLOR, ON BEHALF OF
FIELDSTEAD AND COMPANY, THAT'S
HOWARD AHMANSON JR AND ORANGE
COUNTY PHILANTHROPIST IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. STEVEN SENZER WITH
BROWNSTEIN ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. SHARON GONSALVES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
PALOS VERDES, IS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. KIARA
ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE MARIN
COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND
COUNCIL MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS BRADY
GERNER ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE? PERMANENT FINANCE? NO
FILE. OKAY. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITH. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1893, WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE AB 2243 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? AGAIN, HOLLY, FOR MANY
DAYS WITH LIGHT HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF SPUR CIVIC WELL AND
CALIFORNIA YIMBY. THANK YOU. BOB
NAYLOR FOR FIELDSTEAD IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STEPHEN SPENCER WITH BROWNSTEIN
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
ELISA ACUNA WITH TOWNSEND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF SANTA ANA, NEWPORT BEACH. AND
EXCUSE ME, LA HABRA OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR MEMBERS. BRADY ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES, IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO. FILE
OKAY. SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2243 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 1950 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION? ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? BOB NAYLOR FOR
FIELDSTEAD IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION IN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION ON THIS BILL,
BUT ESTIMATES THAT THIS MAY
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE OF AN UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A NEW
PROGRAM OR HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES. SEEING NO COMMENT OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1950 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2297 HAS MOVED TO THE FLOOR
AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED AND UNDER
THE 28.8 RULE. SO WE'RE MOVING
ON TO AB 2507 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. CLIFF BERG HERE ON BEHALF
OF CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL,
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
OF CALIFORNIA AND JEWISH FREE
LOAN ASSOCIATION, THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM
FOR STUDENTS AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS AND EMERGENCY PILOT
PROGRAM IN A LIMITED NUMBER OF
HIGHER ED FACILITIES, WE ALL
KNOW THAT STUDENTS ARE DROWNING
IN DEBT. WE ALSO KNOW THE STATE
BUDGET DRAMATICALLY CUTS
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS. THIS
BILL PROVIDES AT A VERY MINIMAL
COST $30,000 A YEAR, AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP STUDENTS WHO
ARE MOST AT RISK OF FALLING OUT
OF THE HIGHER ED SYSTEM, WHO ARE
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. IT IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT A NONPROFIT PROGRAM CAN
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS
IN A WAY THAT'S MUCH MORE COST
EFFECTIVE THAN GOVERNMENT. WE
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION ESTIMATES ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF $30,000
PER YEAR TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. FINANCE ESTIMATES THIS
BILL COULD CREATE LIMITED TERM
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES THAT
COULD RANGE FROM THE LOW
MILLIONS TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR THE
DURATION OF THE PROGRAM. TO SEE
THE PROGRAM'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE
LOANS TO ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. THIS
COST PRESSURE WOULD BE DEPENDENT
UPON THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS THAT OPT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE LOAN PROGRAM, AS WELL AS
THE SIZE OF THE LOANS PROVIDED
TO ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. OKAY,
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2507 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2552 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? WEST
HONOLULU FOR KIDS.ORG,
SUPPORTING THIS BILL ALONG WITH
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
FACTS, ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS
AND CA SDC EQUAL GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION. NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. MOMS
ADVOCATING SUSTAINABILITY. YARD
SMART MARIN SONOMA SAS
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, NONTOXIC COMMUNITIES
AND NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
ISABELLA QUINONEZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU, WE
RESPECT THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS,
BUT WE, ARE STILL OPPOSING THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2552 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SENATOR COR.
SO MEMBERS, WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO IS GO BACK TO THE BILLS THAT
WE DID DO PASS ON. AND THEN WE
HAVE ONE MORE THAT WE THAT WE
CAN HEAR, GOING BACK TO AB 1777
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING, THE
MOTION WAS DUE PASS AND, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. JONES HI. JONES.
AYE. 7 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT 7
TO 0. AND THEN NOW WE'LL TAKE
UP, MOVING TO ALMOST THE END OF
THE CALENDAR. AB 3138 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON AND I. MY
UNDERSTANDING, SENATOR BRADFORD,
IS YOU'RE GOING TO BE PRESENTING
THAT BILL. VERY GOOD. THIS IS A
Dð PASS MOTION. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON, I'M HERE FOR
3138, WHICH WOULD MODIFY
EXISTING DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE
PROGRAM TO ALLOW DRIVERS THE
OPTION TO PURCHASE AN AN
ALTERNATIVE DEVICE TO A LICENSE
PLATE OR REGISTRATION CARD THAT
INCLUDES VEHICLE LOCATION
TECHNOLOGY ENDING IN 2027. AS
YOU KNOW, THIS, TEST PILOT HAS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR TEN YEARS,
AND I'LL JUST QUICKLY SPEAK TO
THE FISCAL, FOR OVER A DECADE,
THE DMV IS OFFERING, SOME FORM
OF ALTERNATIVE DEVICES, THROUGH
THE PILOT PROGRAM AND THE FISCAL
IMPACT BY THE DEPARTMENT IS
ANTICIPATED TO BE MINOR, MINOR
OR ABSORBABLE. AGAIN, THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR TEN YEARS
WITH NO PROBLEM. SO HERE TO
TESTIFY MORE SPECIFICALLY AS
ESTEBAN NUNEZ ON BEHALF OF
REVIVER. WELCOME. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ESTEBAN NUNEZ. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF REVIVER, JUST TO KEEP
IT SHORT AND SWEET. AS THE
SENATOR SAID, THIS BILL ADDS
ADDITIONAL GUARDRAILS FOR THE
USE OF ALTERNATIVE DEVICES,
WHICH DMV SAYS CAN BE
ABSORBABLE. THEY'RE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THE REGULATIONS
TO FORMALIZE THE PROGRAM. AND SO
THEY FEEL THAT THEY COULD WHILE
THOSE REGULATIONS ARE STILL
OPEN, STILL ADD TO THEM IN THIS
MANNER. IN ADDITION TO THAT,
THIS THIS BILL SEEKS TO
STREAMLINE COMPLIANCE, WHICH
WOULD SAVE THE DEPARTMENT MONEY
AND TIME OVER, OVER TIME. AND SO
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? BECCA KRAMER MATTER
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN OPPOSITION AB 3138 HAS
SIGNIFICANT COST LIABILITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE FIRST IS REVENUE
LOSS. GPS TRACKER DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATE COMPANY THAT
COMMITTED THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CONTRACTED WITH HAS COMMITTED
DOCUMENTED MALFEASANCE IN
MICHIGAN BY, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
FAILING TO CHECK FOR VEHICLE
REGISTRATION STATUS BEFORE
PUTTING REGISTRATION ON THE
PLATES IF THEY DO SO AGAIN IN
CALIFORNIA, THIS WILL AGAIN
RESULT IN REVENUE LOSS TO THE
STATE DUE TO TAX AVOIDANCE.
ADDITIONALLY, IT PUTS CALIFORNIA
AT RISK FOR LAWSUIT LIABILITY.
THIS SAME COMPANY HAS ALREADY
EXPERIENCED A HACK WHERE THE
HACKER WAS EASILY ABLE TO ACCESS
THE REAL TIME LOCATION OF EVERY
PLATE. WITH THE GPS TRACKER, THE
STATE COULD BE LIABLE IF THERE'S
A SECOND BREACH, CREATING
POTENTIALLY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LAWSUIT LIABILITY FOR THE
STATE. ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE
RIPPLE EFFECT COSTS TO THE STATE
ASSOCIATED WITH TURNING LICENSE
PLATES INTO GPS TRACKING DEVICES
THAT INCREASE RISK TO SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. PEOPLE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA FOR
ABORTIONS OR GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE, LGBTQ TEENS AND OTHERS WHO
MAY FACE HARM FOR TURNING OFF
THE GPS TRACKING. FOR EXAMPLE, A
REPORT BY TULANE UNIVERSITY AND
UC SAN DIEGO FOUND THAT IN 2022
ALONE, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COST
CALIFORNIA NEARLY $74 BILLION,
AUTHORIZING GPS IN DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATES WOULD INCREASE
RISK TO A PERSON WHOSE PARTNER
ABUSES THEM, ESPECIALLY TO
PEOPLE IN RURAL AREAS WITH NO
ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
THEIR PARTNER WOULD KNOW, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF THEY TOOK A CAR TO
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE
PROVIDER. BUT THEY COULD ALSO
FACE DANGEROUS CONSEQUENCES FOR
TURNING OFF THE GPS TRACKER,
PUTTING THEM IN A CATCH 22.
THESE RISKS ARE WHY WE JOINED
WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, LGBTQ
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE, YOUTH AND
PRIVACY ORGANIZATIONS AND
WORKING TO PROHIBIT GPS TRACKERS
IN DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES. Ã
2022 AGREEMENT THAT THIS BILL
WALKS BACK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO, DANNY. KENDALL KAISER, ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, I WILL
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON THE FISCAL
BURDENS. FIRST, THE RULEMAKING
THAT DMV HAS ALREADY DONE WOULD
NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS CHANGES.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE. IT WOULD
INSTEAD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL DMV
RULEMAKING, INCURRING ASSOCIATED
COSTS. SECOND, RECENT BILL
AMENDMENTS. GRANDFATHER IN
EXISTING GPS TRACKER DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATES, CREATING A
CONFLICT WITH THE AUTHOR'S PRIOR
LEGISLATION. AB 984. PER THE
REQUIREMENTS IN SUBPARAGRAPH A
OF PARAGRAPH TWO OF THE
SUBDIVISION OF A OF SECTION
FOUR, EIGHT, FIVE, FOUR OF THE
VEHICLE CODE, AS ADDED IN AB
984. THESE LICENSE PLATES WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE RECALLED BY
JANUARY 1ST OF THIS YEAR. THIS
INDICATES THAT THE VENDOR
REVIVER AND DMV HAVE ALREADY
FAILED TO FOLLOW STATE LAW ON
THIS ISSUE. LASTLY, REVIVER HAS
ALREADY EXPERIENCED ONE ALARMING
SECURITY BREACH IN ITS SYSTEMS
AND HAS RECENTLY FURTHER
DEMONSTRATED, DEMONSTRATED
ISSUES BY FAILING TO FOLLOW
STATE LAW AND ITS CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS WITH THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN. MICHIGAN IS
TERMINATING ITS CONTRACT WITH
REVIVER AFTER ONLY TWO YEARS. IF
THIS IS REPEATED IN CALIFORNIA,
IT WOULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
AND UNKNOWN DMV COSTS TO RECALL
AND REPLACE THE PLATES. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE,
A NO VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO FILE.
OKAY. SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, YOU MAY CONCLUDE, AS
STATED, THIS STRENGTHENS THE
PRIVACY ISSUES THAT THEY WERE
SPEAKING OF AND PROTECTIONS AND
REQUIRES THE DMV TO ISSUE A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE,
ALLOWS DRIVERS TO CONTINUE USING
THE GPS ENABLED ALTERNATIVE
DEVICES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED. SO AGAIN, THE COST
OF THIS BILL ARE MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR OUR AYE VOTE. THIS THE
RECOMMENDATION IS A Dð PASS
MOTION ON THIS. IS THERE, A
MOTION SO MOVED. OKAY, THERE IS
A MOTION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CABALLERO, I JONES, I JONES I
ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER BECKER I
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CIERTO
CIERTO I WAHAB WAHHAB. NO THAT
BILL IS OUT 6 TO 1. THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THAT BILL
SENATOR. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO AB 2496 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, NO. FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2496 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. WE PREVIOUSLY
PREVIOUSLY HEARD AB 2498. SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
2515 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? SHARON GONSALVES ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
AND THE CITY OF ROSEVILLE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL UTILITIES
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
BEST CLEANER FOR KIDS .ORG
CLEANER FOR KIDS OPPOSES AB 2515
UNLESS AMENDED, ALONG WITH THE
FOLLOWING OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
FACTS CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND JUSTICE,
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH,
SONOMA COUNTY YOUTH ACTION
COMMITTEE, AND CA ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS SD SEQUEL,
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION AND
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE THIS, SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2515 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2560 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
WESTERN CORNER FOR KIDS.ORG
OPPOSING AB 2560 ALONG WITH THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS. FACTS
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND JUSTICE
C H ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND
CA SDC GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION AND NORTH COUNTY EQUITY
AND JUSTICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MELISSA SPARKS KRANZ WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. ELISA KONO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF LAGUNA
BEACH, PISMO BEACH, NEWPORT
BEACH, OCEANSIDE, LAFAYETTE,
HALF MOON BAY, DEL MAR AND MORRO
BAY, ALL IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. KIARA ROSS. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF CORONADO AND
SOLANA BEACH IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. NÓ SHARON GONSALVES,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
RANCHO PALOS VERDES AND THE CITY
OF CARLSBAD, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2560 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2783 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION ESTIMATES MINER
COSTS ROUGHLY $50,000 ANNUALLY
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. THOSE COSTS WOULD BE
RECOUPED THROUGH A REIMBURSEMENT
AGREEMENT WITH THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED PORT DISTRICT. THIS BILL
MAY CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE IN THE RANGE OF 100,000
TO $1 MILLION, BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES A DISTRICT TO DEDICATE
2% OF ITS ANNUAL GROSS MARITIME
INDUSTRIAL OPERATING REVENUE TO
ADDRESS OFF TIDELAND IMPACTS
FROM THE DISTRICT'S OPERATIONS.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND CREATE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND COSTS
THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET. VERY GOOD, SEEING
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2783. WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB
2638 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NØ FILE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2638. WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. AB 2893 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE. A FISCAL ESTIMATE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WAS NOT AVAILABLE
AT THE TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS.
HOWEVER, BASED ON THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS, FINANCE
PRELIMINARILY ESTIMATES THAT IT
WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN COSTS IN
THE LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY FOR DHS TO
ESTABLISH A CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES THAT
THE BILL COULD CREATE A MINIMUM
OF $436,000 GENERAL FUND COSTS
ANNUALLY TO CERTIFY
SUBCONTRACTOR FACILITIES.
ADDITIONALLY, CDCR INDICATES
THAT THE BILL CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS COULD CREATE
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES AND
THE LOW MILLIONS ANNUALLY FOR
CDCR. FURTHER, THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS
INDICATES THAT WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL
REQUIRES FOUR POSITIONS AND
$705,000. ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
IN 2025, 26, AND $673,000. ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND IN 20 2627.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE RESULTS IN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS, NOT
INCLUDING THE STATE SPENDING
PLAN, INCLUDING POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSITION 30 STATE
REIMBURSABLE COSTS. VERY GOOD.
LOOK, THEY'RE SEEING NO COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2893 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
3093 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? GOOD
MORNING, KIARA ROSS. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF SOLANA BEACH
AND THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, CAROLINE GRINDER
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES WITH AN
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, SHARON GONSALVES ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF CORONA
AND CARLSBAD IN OPPOSITION AND
THE CITY OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. FILE SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3093 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2672
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO.
FILE SEEING NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2672 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2902 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. CAL RECYCLE ESTIMATES
THE BILL COSTS $345,000 FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND,
ONGOING TO SUPPORT TWO POSITIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING THE
REQUIREMENTS, I BANK NOTES THAT
THEY CAN WORK WITH CAL RECYCLE
TO ENHANCE THEIR UNDERSTANDING
OF OPTIONS AVAILABLE AND CONDUCT
BASIC COORDINATION WITH VARIOUS
RECYCLERS WITH A MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE FISCAL IMPACT.
HOWEVER, IF CAL RECYCLE IS
EXPECTING, I BANK TO CONSULT AS
TO WHAT IS THE BEST FINANCING
FOR EACH DEAL. THIS WILL RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS. CURRENTLY
UNKNOWN. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN ONGOING
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE MULTI
YEAR CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE
PLAN OF THE 2024 BUDGET
AGREEMENT, AND CREATES
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. VERY GOOD SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB 2902 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2903 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOOVER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BY THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2903 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3061 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? NO FILE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3061 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE, WE ALREADY
TOOK UP AB 3138, SO WE'LL MOVE
ON TO AB 3238 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
HAS WAIVED. PRESENTATION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? HOW SLOW? I'M
SORRY. CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. YOU WERE HIDING
BEHIND THE POLE? YEAH IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION? EITHER ONE.
OPPOSITION, PLEASE. WEST. ONLY
WITH CLEANER FOR KIDS.ORG.
OPPOSING AB 3238. ALSO OPPOSING
ARE FACTS CALIFORNIA NURSE
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND CA SDCL
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION,
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
AND NONTOXIC COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY,
EITHER IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. VERY GOOD.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 3238. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SO THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
FOR TODAY. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO CAME TO TESTIFY
AND PARTICIPATED IN THIS PROCESS.
AND, WE ARE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.